et moscou juge erronés d'amputer toute
la responsabilité de la crise à minsk le
porte parole du kremlin s'est exprimé ce
matin moscou prête à apporter son aide
pour résoudre la situation la
correspondance de vera goffman
moscou est prête à servir de médiateur
dans le règlement de la crise des
réfugiés à la frontière de la pologne de
la biélorussie a déclaré le porte parole
du kremlin dmitri peskov hélas celui
qu'il s'agissait uniquement de rôle
d'intermédiaire dans le processus des
pourparlers dmitri peskov a également
répondu à la déclaration du secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken qui
estime qu'avec la crise des réfugiés
là aussi c'est de détourner l'attention
à propos de ces actions présumées en
ukraine je vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine a absolument exclu la
possibilité d'une quelconque implication
de la russie dans ce qui se passe autour
des migrants à la frontière polono
biélorusse
[Musique]
et le président a expliqué pourquoi la
situation à la frontière n'a pas non
plus été créée par loukachenko comme le
dit le président il s'agit de migrants
qui veulent obtenir l'asile en europe et
qui arrivent grâce au régime de
circulation sans visa on ne leur donne
pas on ne les laisse pas passer
dans l'espoir de rejoindre l'union
européenne des milliers de migrants sont
actuellement installés dans les camps de
fortune à la frontière entre la pologne
et la biélorussie des ong alerte sur la
situation humanitaire notamment à cause
des températures glaciales sur place
alors que des barrages de policiers et
de militaires sont présents de part et
d'autre de la frontière